(robotic dinging)
- [Announcer] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website,
or follow us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(light, upbeat music)
- Good afternoon and welcome.
My name is Mary Comerio.
I am Professor of the Graduate School
in the College of Environmental Design
and Chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We are pleased, along
with the Graduate Council,
to present Paul Goldberger,
this year's speaker,
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
As a condition of this bequest,
we are obligated and
very happy to tell you
how the endowment came to UC Berkeley.
And it's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
in which the campus is linked
to the history of California
and to the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the Army,
came to San Francisco during the Gold Rush
where he opened a thriving practice.
In 1885, Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley, as an expression
of his long-held interest in education.
His daughter, Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco
for her colorful personality as well as
her generosity, greatly
expanded her father's
original gift to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley, making it possible for us
to present this series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become
one of the most cherished
endowments of the
University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank You Lillie and Charles,
and now a few words about Paul Goldberger.
Paul Goldberger holds
the Joseph Urban Chair
in Design and Architecture
at The New School
located in New York City.
He is a Contributing Editor to Vanity Fair
and has been called the leading figure
in architectural criticism
by the Huffington Post.
Until 2011, he wrote the
popular Sky Line column
for The New Yorker and served
as the magazine's architectural critic.
He began his career in journalism
at the New York Times where
he won the Pulitzer Prize
for Distinguished Criticism in 1984.
Goldberger's first
lecture will be an inquiry
as to whether cities are
becoming more and more the same,
and why, and what the
implications for this are.
The second lecture will discuss
the question of whether
or even if the premise
of the first lecture is true.
Cities, nevertheless, remain catalysts
for creativity and why.
A prolific writer, Goldberger
just completed a biography
of Frank Gehry to be
published by Alfred Knopf
this coming September,
titled Building Art,
The Life and Work of Frank Gehry.
He has many other books,
most recent meaning
is Why Architecture Matters,
but I am not gonna read
you this entire list.
We wanna hear him not me.
He has, however, chronicled the process
of rebuilding Ground Zero, Up From Zero,
Politics, Architecture and the Rebuilding
of New York, which was
published in New York in 2004
and was named a New
York Times Notable Book.
He was educated at Yale University
and has received honorary
doctorates from Pratt Institute,
the University of Miami, Kenyon College
and the College of Creative Studies
and the New York School
of Interior Design.
He is a former Dean of
Parsons School of Design,
a Division of The New School,
and has taught at Yale
and the Graduate School of
Journalism at UC Berkeley.
He is a frequent lecturer
on architecture design,
historic preservation and cities,
often appearing in film and television.
He served as an architectural adviser
to major cultural and
educational institutions.
He has received many awards.
I will only name two.
The medal of the American
Institute of Architects
and the Medal of Honor of the New York
Landmarks Preservation Foundation.
Please join me in welcoming
Paul Goldberger to Berkeley.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much Mary.
This is the most wonderful
old Berkeley room,
I have to say, actually.
it's a great pleasure
and an even greater honor
to be here, and to join
this extraordinary series
of Hitchcock professors
who've come to Berkeley
over the last hundred years.
For all that we're invited
to give of our knowledge,
I suspect that most Hitchcock professors
have received far more than they've given.
And I know that that
will be my case as well,
so I'm especially
appreciative of the invitation
to be on this extraordinary campus again.
Now I'm gonna talk this week,
as you've heard, about cities,
what they mean right now in our culture
and what we can make of them now
in the early decades of the 21st century,
about what cities are now and
about what they ought to be.
I should tell you now,
right at the outset,
that I've decided to make this talk
something of a revolt against the thing
that seems now all too often to define
the modern lecture, which is PowerPoint.
I'm gonna do something that is rare
in the realm of lectures,
particularly in the realm
of lectures that have some connection
to architecture and architectural history,
which is to talk without images.
It's a little bit, I know,
like walking a tightrope without
a net, but I will try it.
I'm doing it because I
think a lot of the things
I wanna talk about are
familiar to most of you.
I'll talk a lot about San
Francisco and the Bay Area
both today and tomorrow,
and also because I'd like to
talk a fair amount about ideas
and I think that's more important
than showing you a parade of images.
I think you have enough
images in your head already
to understand where I'll be going
over the next few minutes.
And the other reason I've decided
to steer clear of PowerPoint
is because I am not interested in using it
to throw data at you.
We're deluged with data today.
And while much of it is useful
and some of it even has the
added benefit of being true,
I don't think the points I
want to make are best explained
by a cascade of numbers.
Now today's talk is
entitled The Generic City,
Can the 21st Century Ever
Build Special Places?
A question that I hope is
not entirely rhetorical.
Tomorrow I'll talk
about The Creative City,
Why Cities Remain the
Catalysts of Creativity,
and I recognize that there might seem
to be a bit of a contradiction
between these two topics.
Obviously the two talks
were conceived as a pair,
but it would be a mistake
to think of the first as pessimistic,
intended to suggest that the city today
is nothing but a generic banal place,
the victim of the global monoculture,
and that the talk I'll give
tomorrow is optimistic,
intended to make the point that
everything is fine after all
because good things still
happen in these dreary places.
It's not nearly so simple as that.
And I'm not sure in the end
that it wouldn't be more accurate to say
that today and tomorrow I'll
be looking at the same subject
through slightly different lenses
and showing how it is possible
to look at the contemporary city
and come to very different conclusions
about what it is, how it functions
and what it means for our culture.
But that's getting ahead of the story.
Let me start by going back
40 or 50 years to the cities
of the 1960s and 1970s,
when in the in the United States
and in much of the rest of the world
if you did a free association
test with the word urban,
the answer you would probably
come up with most often
would be crisis, or problem, or challenge.
The urban crisis was a given.
Cities were harsh, dirty and dangerous.
And in this country at least,
if you could afford to live somewhere else
you quite often did.
The Asian cities that now loom so large,
were large, but they did not loom.
They had very little to
do with the global economy
and they were technologically backward.
The major cities on the world stage
were European and American
for the most part,
and a great many of them were a mess.
I began my own professional
life in New York
in the 1970s and when I talk about it
I realize that the city
I remember from my 20s
is as disconnected from the reality
of what students know today,
as the world of The Depression
that my parents and
grandparents talked about
was disconnected from
the reality that I knew.
I don't know that New York in the 1970s
was as truly horrific
as it was made out to be
in the various movies of the age,
like Taxi Driver and The
Taking of Pelham 123,
but it wasn't pretty.
It was dirty and ill-kempt.
The subway, though it wasn't really
too dangerous to ride in,
was dirty and full of graffiti
and various unsavory
types, especially at night
and it had a weird tendency
to stop between stations
mysteriously as if the
equipment had broken down
and there was either no announcement
of what the problem was or a message
over a malfunctioning PA system
that sounded sort of
like (speaks gibberish).
Now in those days I worked
at the New York Times,
which was located logically
enough at Times Square,
which was not the prettified
somewhat Disneyfied
tourist environment it is now.
It was more of an amalgam
of sleazy movie theaters,
many pornographic striptease joints,
massage parlors, pickpockets,
muggers, you name it,
all wrapped in a dazzling
array of lights and signs.
I remember from time to time
seeing the occasional tourist
wandering around dazed and confused
and wishing I could say to them,
can't I take you to the
Metropolitan Museum,
the Museum of Modern Art, somewhere else
so you don't think this is
all there is to New York.
You really did feel that the public realm
was in disarray, that no one was in charge
or that the people who
were nominally in charge
had no power to fix what was broken,
that even the best of the public officials
seemed rather hapless,
bewildered by the challenges they faced.
We seemed unable to keep
Central Park clean and safe
let alone the subway system.
And while there were
occasional extravaganzas
that distracted everyone
from the immediate
problems at hand, such as the
famous Be-Ins in Central Park
that attracted thousands, often to protest
the Vietnam War, remember
this was the 1960s.
These events, inspiring though they were,
only caused Frederick Law Olmsted's
astonishingly great work of landscape
to deteriorate further because nobody
was putting any money into maintenance
and the park, like everything
else, was falling apart.
Large corporations wanted none of this
and dozens of them
moved their headquarters
out of the city.
Most often, as the great urbanologist,
William H. Whyte discovered,
to a suburban location
in Connecticut or Westchester
County or New Jersey
that just happened to
be within a few miles
of where the chief executive lived.
Now there I admit is a piece of data
that was quite useful to have turned up.
The city seemed to be losing
not only its middle class
which had always struggled somewhat
under urban pressures but its upper class,
the people who in past generations
had sailed blithely over
everything and everyone else.
It was terrifyingly
easy to buy real estate
because nobody wanted it.
You could buy great
apartments on Fifth Avenue
facing Central Park for
$100,000 for even less.
A sum that today, in New York,
won't buy you a one room studio apartment
in a marginal neighborhood.
If things were happening anywhere
it was in places like Houston,
where there was still plenty of money
and a fundamentally
suburban corporate culture
that had only minimal interest
in what we might call or
would come to call later
a culture of urbanism,
a culture of cities.
Let me talk for a moment
about that culture
which was hardly limited to Houston.
It was really the American culture
and it was a culture whose
fundamental characteristic
at least so far as urbanism was concerned
was that it valued the private realm
over the public realm.
The public realm, such
as it was, was disdained,
distrusted or ignored.
I'm not sure it was ever
even really understood
because when the public
realm was really functioning
in the great days of American urbanism,
the decades before World War II,
it was just a natural thing
that people took for granted,
like the air you breathed
and the water you drank.
You didn't think you were
experiencing the public realm
when you walked down Main
Street and went shopping,
or when you took a stroll in the park.
These were just the
natural things that you did
and I don't think there was much
consciousness of how important it was
because it seemed like such
a natural part of life,
not just in a big city but
in a small town or village,
where the parks and village squares
and sidewalks lined with stores
were as much a part of life as the schools
and the churches and the houses.
But by the 1950s we'd begun
to stop investing in this.
We weren't conscious of how
much the public realm meant.
How it was really the most important thing
the city could possibly symbolize,
had always symbolized, which is the idea
of common ground.
The notion that the city expresses
in physical form, the commonweal,
and that the public
realm stands for the way
in which our diverse complex society
can come together.
Not by papering over our differences
but by acknowledging
them, and by so doing,
helping us to transcend them.
These are always our aspirations
and it is in the nature of the city
to facilitate them by
privileging public space
over private space.
But come the 1960s and 1970s,
as with Central Park, so was it through
much of the United States.
We couldn't even take care
of the public realm we had
let alone build any more of it.
We didn't seem to want
to build more of it,
that's my real point, that society seemed
to have given up on
caring about the notion
of public space, the
idea of the commonweal
as being represented by
our common public realm.
The suburbs and the automobile culture,
of course do the exact opposite of this.
They privilege private
space over public space.
And while I do not mean to
lay all of our urban issues
at the foot of the automobile,
there is no question that it
has been a nearly constant
enemy of cities.
But there is something
about the urban idea
and something about the automobile
that are in some fundamental
way incompatible.
When you make a city work
well for the automobile
it almost invariably works
less well for the pedestrian.
The car is itself a form of public space,
private space rather, excuse me.
The car is itself a form of private space.
And when you are in it
you are disconnected
from everything except
that which you choose
to connect yourself to.
Be it music, conversation, your smartphone
or, as is increasingly the
situation with children
sitting in the backseat, television,
all of which somehow
seemed to have the effect
not only of disconnecting people in a car
from the world around them
but also from each other.
Now I am really not here to
rant about the automobile,
as I said, or about technology.
But it is hard not to think that so far as
the meaning of urban space is concerned
technology does not always connect us
as we like to think.
In some ways it separates us.
Cars are private pods zipping
around in public space
rendering it effectively private.
But then again people on telephones
and listening to their iPods
are in private space as well,
disconnected from the
people and the environment
that is all around them.
The automobile and of course the airplane
changed our sense of place,
and by making us mobile,
and less wedded to a single place
than our ancestors were,
but the technology of today
goes that one better,
and allows us wherever
we may physically be
to function as if we were somewhere else.
In effect, technology allows you
to have a virtual presence anywhere
which is wonderful until you realize
that this has the result, in some ways,
of making you feel like you are less
where you really are.
And it makes all places
seem more or less the same.
You know, once your very telephone number
was a kind of badge of place,
a sign of where you were.
You couldn't be reached unless you
actually were in that place,
on that piece of earth
connected to that telephone,
that instrument that we now
quaintly call a landline.
It's increasingly common, I realize,
for cell phone conversations to begin
with the question, where are you?
And for the answer of
course to be anything
from out by the pool to Madagascar.
Now I don't miss the
age when phone charges
were based on distance, but that did have
the beneficial effect
of at least reinforcing
a sense that places were distinguishable
from one another.
Now, with your cell phone,
calling across the street
and calling from New York to California
are precisely the same thing.
They cost the same because, to the phone,
they are the same.
Every place is just a node on a network.
And so, increasingly,
are we, that's my point.
Before we even get into the question
of whether all places
are physically the same,
the idea I've called the generic city.
We can see that all places
are equally accessible
and that wherever we are,
we are no longer rooted in that place
in the way that we once were.
We may be physically in one place
but we are now virtually
anywhere and everywhere.
Before we move on entirely from technology
I would like to come
back for just one moment
and make another point that is relevant
to the larger question here
and connects to the arguments
that Dr. Richard Jackson at UCLA
has been making for years,
which is that the places
in which people drive all the time
are inherently unhealthy.
If you need to walk you will,
and as a consequence you are healthier.
If you don't need to
walk you probably won't
or at least you will walk a lot less
and you will be less healthy.
Health of course correlates to many things
and not just this one, but Dr. Jackson
has done a vital service to the world
of architecture and planning in giving us
another set of reasons for believing
that the traditional dense
pedestrian-oriented city
is a good thing.
Many architects and
planners have believed this
for a long time.
And from time to time there
has been other evidence
about the benefits to the social fabric
inherent in denser pedestrian-oriented
towns and villages,
not to mention the benefits
in terms of energy use and sustainability.
But Dr. Jackson has shown us
that the greatest sustainability
we get from traditional cities
is that we ourselves are sustained,
because we are healthier.
There I concede is another instance
in which some hard data is useful,
even though I'm not focusing
on quantifiable data this afternoon.
I want instead to talk
about the nature of place
and about what gives a place its identity.
Here in the Bay Area that
question is an easy one.
It is the bay itself, the
natural landscape of the hills,
the landmarks of San Francisco,
the Golden Gate Bridge, the Bay Bridge,
the tower on this campus,
the Maybach buildings
and the other classic
buildings of Berkeley
just for a start.
We could go on and on.
No one has ever confused the Bay Area
with any place else, and so, in a way,
this is an odd place
in which to be talking
about this problem because it barely seems
to be a problem here.
But let's go down the peninsula a bit
to Silicon Valley, to San
Jose, to Mountain View
and Menlo Park and Palo Alto.
Stanford aside, sorry I've mentioned
that unmentionable thing.
I should have thought this through
a little more carefully, I apologize.
Anyway an unmentionable
private university aside,
it is a landscape that looks
pretty much like other landscapes,
until recently at least,
when a new whole new
wave of building began.
There wasn't much to tell
you that this was the place
in which the world was being remade.
In which the technology
of the 21st century
was being developed and the great fortunes
of our time made.
What it was, for most of it,
was a banal suburban landscape.
A place that looked like other places,
and I should add, a place that depended
almost entirely on the automobile.
Indeed for a long time
the most notable thing
about the appearance of Silicon Valley
was how ordinary it was.
How much it looked like every place else,
or at least like every other collection
of reasonably prosperous American suburbs.
Yes it had that campus and
some handsome mountain scenery
marking its western edge.
But the rest of the place
has always been made up
of places that could
have been almost anywhere
like the 101 Freeway and the strip malls
and the supermarkets
and the car dealerships
and motels and low-rise office parks.
Even after a few people
began doing unusual things
in their garages, and other people
started inventing things
in university laboratories
and even after some of these
turned into the beginnings
of large corporations,
even then Silicon Valley
didn't look very different
from everyplace else.
It was a landscape of
freeways and strip malls.
There was certainly
nothing about it that told
you that this was a place
that had generated more
wealth than anywhere else
in our time.
Or, more to the point,
the place that seemed
to demonstrate more creative imagination
than any other place in our time.
You could go so far as to
say that at least for a while
a determined indifference
to the physical world
seemed an inherent part of the identity
of Silicon Valley.
In the same way that you
don't expect computer geeks
to pay much attention to their wardrobes,
it didn't seem odd that the Valley towns
had a dull anywhere USA veneer
or that the biggest and
most successful companies
seemed to operate out
of low-rise buildings
that looked as if they'd been built
off the Long Island Expressway
to house insurance agencies.
It wasn't just because most of them
started out on a shoestring
and took what space they could
progressing from a garage
to random office space
wherever they could find it.
It was also because, Steve Jobs aside,
most people in Silicon
Valley didn't care much
about what things looked like.
Buildings were kind of whatever,
just like clothing, which is why
the first Silicon Valley structures
were to architecture as the
hoodie is to haberdashery.
(audience laughs)
All of this is now changing rapidly
in a number of ways.
There's a surge of interest
in ambitious pieces of architecture
now in Silicon Valley, driven partly
by Steve Jobs's desire
shortly before his death
to create a home for Apple
that would be as refined a work of design
as Apple's products are.
The new Apple headquarters
by Norman Foster
looks rather too much
like an Apple product,
in my view.
I think it's an object more
than a work of architecture,
an iPod blown up to gargantuan scale.
But that's another
discussion for another day.
Suffice it to say that
Apple raised the bar.
And Facebook followed
commissioning Frank Gehry
to design a new complex
that has just been finished
and now Google is beginning
work on a new headquarters
designed by the Bjarke Ingels Group,
the Copenhagen architect
now resettled in New York
and Thomas Heatherwick,
the London designer.
These companies are now so large
and there is so much
money connected to them
and more importantly so much determination
to play a conspicuous role in the culture
that architecture inevitably
had to enter the picture.
The people whose job it is to
make the virtual world for us
had to acknowledge that they
wanted a better presence
in the physical world.
How successful all of this will be
remains to be seen, but it is surely
making Silicon Valley far less the generic
almost banal environment that it has been
for so long.
The other way in which this is changing
is arguably more important,
but I'll talk more about that
tomorrow since it
involves a profound change
in the relationship between the Valley
and the city of San Francisco,
and says a lot about the role of the city
as a creative engine.
So I'll come back to Silicon Valley
and to San Francisco tomorrow
and look at their relationship
from a very different standpoint,
I think a more positive one.
But for now let's go to
some other large cities,
to ones that are not San Francisco,
and talk for a moment about how they work
at this moment in time.
I think it's almost a truism to state
that cities are more alike
than they used to be.
The experience of arrival
into similar looking airports,
the trip to the center of the city
often takes you along similar freeways
past similar landscapes.
And upon arrival in the center city
you see similar skyscrapers.
You unpack your bags in a hotel
that could be anywhere and it doesn't even
have to be a tired Hilton or Marriott.
It might even be a trendy W or Andaz,
and it is still the same or feels the same
from city to city.
You take a walk and grab a snack
at the Shake Shack or you shop at J.Crew
or Ralph Lauren or Williams-Sonoma
or whatever, the same
places you find at home.
But it is not just the places
that are increasingly the same.
It is also all of us.
We are more the same
because we are less shaped
by the culture of our individual places
in which we live and more shaped
by the culture of the world
which we are exposed to
at every moment thanks to technology.
We must not underestimate
the extent to which
if places feel the same, it
is because the people in them
are more the same than they once were.
It can be anywhere, as I said,
before it amounts in a
sense to being nowhere.
Nowhere, that is, except
in the virtual any place,
every place that is the
world of technology,
accessible to all of us.
Now every place is, to a
greater or lesser extent,
a product of its time.
Cities built in the 18th century,
at least in this country,
had certain similarities
as did cities built in the 19th
and cities built in the 20th.
I say that not to deny
regional or cultural
or geographical
differences, but to suggest
that time has always played some role
in shaping urban identity.
I'll say more about that in a minute.
But I think that the factor of time
will become ever more important
as cultural and geographical influences
become less important.
They will become less important
because every place is
exposed to the same ones.
The forces that made Paris
different from London,
that made Rome grow into a place
different from Milan or Jerusalem
or Istanbul or Tokyo.
Those forces no longer exist.
Those seven places are now
exposed to and shaped by similar forces
as global culture continues to homogenize.
This has been understood,
if not always welcomed,
as a byproduct of
modernism for a long time.
Marshall McLuhan spoke
of the Global Village,
although he said later
that he did not envision
the connections wrought by technology
as reducing differences as
they appear to have done.
In 1932 Henry Russell
Hitchcock and Philip Johnson
coined the term the International Style
to represent the austere minimalist
modern architecture
that they saw correctly
was moving rapidly across the globe.
They were of course celebrating its spread
not thinking about its consequences.
Okay, we all know that globalization,
which often means the
increasing westernization
of all places, has a staggering impact
and that in the face of this
it has become becoming harder and harder
for places to maintain a clear physical,
not to say cultural identity.
What can we do about this?
Let me bring our focus
back to architecture
by quoting from a recent blog posting
by the architecture
critic Witold Rybczynski,
who tried to tie this to
the never-ending debate
in the world of architecture about,
and I apologize for using this
ersatz word, starchitects.
The celebrated architects
who travel around the globe
dropping new buildings into cities
and then moving on to the next.
You know who I mean.
Norman Foster, Renzo Piano, Zaha Hadid,
Frank Gehry, Rem Koolhaas, Jean Nouvel,
are at the top of the list right now.
Rybczynski said that such hype and,
quote, high-powered architects diminished
rather than helped cities largely because
they don't understand the
places in which they build.
And he suggested that
globe-trotting architects
merely delivered the
shapes that interested them
with little concern for context.
In the long rise, in the long run,
it's wiser to nurture
local talent, he said,
instead of starchitects, locatects.
But is this so?
And if skylines around the world
are looking too much the same
is this because the new
and important buildings
are done by the big names from far away
and not by the locals?
I'm actually more inclined to think
that the opposite is true.
That the distinguishing new buildings
in many cities are the very ones
that were done by outsiders.
Cesar Pelli's Petronas Towers in Malaysia,
Kohn Pedersen Fox's Shanghai
World Center in Shanghai
and Mori Tower in Tokyo.
Jean Nouvel's Torre Agbar in Barcelona.
Frank Gehry's Eight Spruce
Street Tower in New York
and Renzo Piano's Shard in London.
No, they're not all great,
but they're distinctive
and they help give their cities skylines
that push back against
the forces of sameness,
the tendencies toward the generic.
In Tokyo, KAJIMA DESIGN,
an enormous design
and construction firm that
is as local as you can get
designed NTT Docomo Yoyogi Building,
the eighth tallest building in Japan,
and a conspicuous element on the skyline
to look like a knockoff of
the Empire State Building.
So much for the natives
having an innate feel
for the DNA of a particular place.
I'll take the work of the carpetbagger
over that kind of local any day.
Even taller than the NTT is
the new Toranomon Hills Tower
designed by another Japanese
megafirm Nihon Seiki
and it looks a lot like the angled
slightly sculpted glass towers
that you see in almost every city
in the United States.
I don't see much that
is inherently Tokyoesque
in either of these skyscrapers.
And I've been talking
only about skyscrapers,
the buildings that define the skyline.
Museums, civic center's, concert halls,
bridges, libraries, opera houses
all give cities part of
their identity as well
and many of the ones that succeed best
and make places feel
special were not designed
by local architects
either, but by architects
who were hired because it was thought
that they could bring more imagination
and a sense of freshness to the problem.
And often enough they have.
One of the best new
buildings I saw last summer
was the expansion of
the Clark Art Institute
in Williamstown, Massachusetts,
by the Japanese architect Tadao Ando,
who was about as un-Berkshires
as you could get.
Everybody knows how successful
Frank Gehry's Guggenheim
Museum in Bilbao Spain is,
but I'm mystified as to
why Witold Rybczynski
felt compelled to say in
that piece I was quoting
that Gary's Walt Disney
Concert Hall in Los Angeles
is superior to it, and I quote,
because Gary knows and
understands Los Angeles
better than Bilbao.
I admire both buildings,
but if you ask me,
Bilbao is the one that actually shows
a more inventive, understanding
and subtle connection
to its urban context
than Gary's concert hall
in his home city.
By the same token, is
Norman Foster's round
Gherkin skyscraper really
a better addition to London
than his Hearst Tower in New York?
Because Foster, again I
quote, exhibits a surer touch
on his home ground?
Foster actually hasn't lived in London
in more than a decade, though
his firm is based there.
For many years he's lived
part time in New York
and part time in Switzerland,
and his building in Midtown Manhattan
possesses a swagger that
makes it, to my mind,
very much in character with its place.
But to Rybczynski, the Hearst Tower
is not New York enough
because it's sculptural shape
stopped abruptly on the 46th floor
to give way to a flat top.
I bow to no one in my love of the crown
to the Chrysler Building
or the Woolworth Building
and the Empire State Building,
but I hardly see how that means
that the flat-topped Seagram Building
by Mies van der Rohe of Chicago
or the CBS Building by Eero Saarinen,
then of Bloomfield Hills, Michigan,
were inappropriate to New York.
Iconic structures confer
a sense of identity
on a city at least as much as
they reflect that identity.
That's where the issue of
urban identity gets interesting
in my mind, if not a little perplexing.
By that I mean there was
nothing particularly Parisian
about the Eiffel Tower until it was built.
And now, of course, for much of the world,
for all of us in this room
surely, it defines Paris.
What made it Parisian?
Certainly not its height, since Paris,
either then or now, was not known
as a city of tall structures.
Yes, Gustave Eiffel was a great engineer
and there was a tradition of
advanced engineering in France
but France was not unique in this regard.
The fact that the tower
combines engineering brilliance
with a lyrical beauty and that this
is particularly Parisian, maybe.
But you could say the same thing
about Eero Saarinen and the St. Louis Arch
or the CN Television Tower in Toronto,
each of which has made its
form symbolic of its city,
and by doing so has rescued the skylines
of those cities from ordinariness.
If the lyricism of the Eiffel Tower
made it right for Paris,
what is there about the graceful curves
of the St. Louis Arch
that speaks to something
in the nature of St. Louis?
Nothing, that's my point.
We conferred the St.
Louisness, so to speak,
on it later, which is how this process
almost always works.
Surely the quirky Transamerica Pyramid
by William Pereira, now is identifiable,
a part of the San Francisco skyline
as the towers of the bridges
was not inherently San Franciscan.
But it come to be identified with the city
perhaps only because the very quirkiness
that made critics dislike it at first
has made it memorable over the years.
And as the association with the city
has grown and developed.
Now of course, so many huge skyscrapers
have been built, the Transamerica
which once seemed to punctuate the skyline
is now barely visible within it.
But again the point is that there was
not much about this building
that automatically made it
right for San Francisco.
Over time it has become so.
By the same token I
would even venture to say
that the only thing that made
the Empire State Building
feel like it belonged
in the New York of 1931
was its height.
The Empire State's magnificent profile,
the thing that really
says New York to us now
and is as much a symbol of the city
as the Statue of Liberty,
was the creation of its architects,
Shreve, Lamb and Harmon.
And it had no precise precedent.
It was an invented symbol
and it has served us
and its city just fine.
So the problem isn't
the famous architects.
It's the banal and unimaginative buildings
designed by other architects,
and the fact that the
skylines of most cities
are made up of too many
mediocre buildings that are
much too big.
Of course we don't like them.
I would venture to say that a lot
of the complaints about cities
looking all the same these days,
complaints that, as
I've said, I agree with
to a large extent, nevertheless
are really complaints
about too much building, period.
If those buildings were better
and not all so big, I guarantee
that people wouldn't hate them so much,
no matter how many of them there were.
The real problem for most people
isn't that the buildings are the same
from city to city, it is that there are
too many buildings and
that they are too big.
Case in point, let's go back a little more
than a hundred years to the
heyday of the Beaux-Arts
in the United States.
When architects were
contorting classical temples
into art museums, courthouses, libraries,
city halls and even, yes, skyscrapers.
They were doing it in cities
all across the country
and they weren't making
the actual buildings
all that different from city to city.
Cleveland's skyline for years was defined
mainly by the terminal tower.
A late 1920s masterpiece
with a classical top
designed by the Chicago architects
Graham, Anderson, Probst and White,
who more or less copied the crown
of the Municipal Building
by McKim, Mead and White.
Nobody complained that the buildings
in those two cities were similar
or too generic.
They've always been so well liked
that it hardly seemed to matter.
I don't think there were ever complaints
that the Palace Hotel in San Francisco
looked like it could
have been built in Boston
or New York, where its architects,
Trowbridge and Livingston,
did similar hotels.
This was a time when scale,
by and large, was reasonable.
When very large buildings
were the exception
and not the rule, and when
the natural order of things
gave us cities that were more
or less comfortable places,
at least if you were
not in the lowest rungs
of the economic ladder and stuck
in a tiny tenement apartment
with a shared bathroom.
The natural order of things
did not give us housing
for everyone that met minimum standards,
and that did not happen
until planners intervened
with building codes and zoning laws.
But a hundred years ago it did not take
either building codes or zoning laws
or the intervention of
planners and urban designers
to give us so many of the neighborhoods
of San Francisco and Berkeley
that we still cherish and admire,
or Greenwich Village or Beacon Hill
or Georgetown, the last
three being places,
by the way, that seem to have
just the right amount
of individual identity,
but which also shared a great deal
from city to city.
And it wasn't only attractive
residential neighborhoods
that were similar from city to city.
You could say the same
thing about the museums
and courthouses and state
capitals all over the country.
They were widely accepted and admired
despite how similar they were
from one place to the next.
Yes, there was plenty of dissent
from the likes of Louis
Sullivan and Frank Lloyd Wright
who hated the Beaux-Arts,
and thought classicism
was the scourge of the age,
But that's another issue.
Sullivan, for his part,
built office towers
in St. Louis and Buffalo
that were sublime,
but not, when you get right down to it,
all that different from each other.
He may have been a genius,
but he was not always
much for genius loci.
And Wright, well the Guggenheim Museum
is one of the greatest things ever built
in New York City, but
you're on pretty thin ice
if you try to say that
Wright was reflecting
the spirit of New York
when he designed it.
He was doing exactly the opposite.
He was giving New York a new spirit
that in time would become a key part
of the city's identity.
Most of those traditional architects
were quite happy to jump from city to city
designing more or less similar buildings.
Just as Witold Rybczynski
accuses today's big names of doing.
Henry Hobson Richardson was
the starchitect par excellence
of the 1880s, and Richardsonian
Romanesque buildings
in imitation of his style
went up in every major city
from Boston to San Francisco,
not to mention Minneapolis, Dallas,
Denver and St. Louis.
But you didn't hear anyone complain
that those cities looked generic.
McKim, Mead and White, based in New York
built magnificently in the late 19th
and early 20th centuries in Boston,
Chicago, Kansas City, Providence,
Minneapolis, Washington and even Rome.
So you could call them
the first global stars.
But they weren't the only ones.
Daniel Burnham, the Chicagoan
who is celebrated for
the Flatiron Building
in New York and Union
Station in Washington, D.C.,
also built Selfridges
Department Store in London,
a wonderful, wonderful building,
but one that, if truth be told,
has nothing particularly British about it.
But we can't deny, as I said before,
that globalization has made things
different in architecture
as it has in everything.
Daniel Burnham had to
sail across the ocean
to work on Selfridges, and his trips
probably spanned weeks.
He inevitably immersed
himself in life in London
and experienced it in a way
that is totally different
from an international architect of today
who spends his or her
life in constant motion.
That same Burnham,
one of our first
architectural powerhouses,
came to San Francisco in 1904,
invited by the city's business leaders
to design a plan.
He and his wife stayed for two weeks
and as his biographer
Thomas Hinds tells us,
he, and I quote, explored in great detail
talking, dining and socializing
with personal friends
and with civic and Association officials.
He swam and fished in the ocean at Carmel
and he particularly enjoyed
the exciting novelty
of touring by automobile.
He gave speeches and
shared his initial ideas
then returned to his office in Chicago
to think about the city
for several more weeks,
then requested that upon his return
he be provided with an office
in a structure atop Twin Peaks
so that he could be
where the, and I quote,
from Burnham now, where
the influence about me
shall stimulate Golden Gate thoughts.
Downtown, Burnham thought, would not do
since he needed a place where he could
see and grasp the city's
remarkable landscape
in its entirety.
Weeks and weeks of deep engagement
and a desire to have a
big picture of the city
in front of him at all times.
So what did Burnham
produce the following year
when his plan for San
Francisco was finished?
A plan whose most significant element
was the Civic Center, the
area at Market and Van Ness
where City Hall and other
civic structures are clustered.
And the place that I think
all of us would agree
is just about the least
San Francisco-like part
of the entire city,
whatever its other virtues.
Burnham was trained in the Beaux-Arts
and he liked its grand classical buildings
and formal axial boulevards.
He proposed several wide diagonal avenues
for San Francisco that,
unlike the Civic Center,
were never built.
There's another irony to
Daniel Burnham's involvement
in San Francisco, which
is that the element
in the city that he most disliked
and wished to obliterate,
though he knew he couldn't
was the city street grid.
It denied the special qualities
of the city's great
Hills, Burnham thought,
and he pretended that the city's,
oh no, and rather and he believed the grid
pretended that the city's
magnificent topography
did not exist.
By rejecting the city's straight streets
even knowing he was stuck
with most of them anyway,
Burnham thought that he was proving
how well he understood the city
and how much his plan
spoke to San Francisco's unique nature,
how much it was not
generic in other words.
But as all of you know,
the relentlessness of the grid
across San Francisco striking topography
is in itself one of the key elements
of the city's identity.
It provides a kind of drama
that exists nowhere else
and makes real and
powerful the juxtaposition
of the man-made world and
an unusual natural feature.
Paradoxically, if the grid
could've been made to disappear
and Burnham's preferred plan
for curving contoured roadways
wrapping around the hills
and gradually climbing up them
had been brought into being,
San Francisco might have
felt less distinctive
not more distinctive.
Sometimes the best way to play
to the character of a place
is to do the conventional thing
where it might be least expected.
Still, Burnham's deep
engagement with San Francisco
and his sincere attempt
to respond to its unique qualities,
whether or not he
succeeded, can't be doubted.
And this could not be more different
from how things work today,
with architects flying in and flying out.
Today, Burnham would have
flown to San Francisco
from his home in Chicago,
been given a helicopter tour
and been back home in
Chicago the next day,
or maybe on to Singapore.
And we all would have seen his
proposals for San Francisco
the moment they came out of his computer.
Unlike in 1905, when he presented his plan
in the form of an
elaborately printed book,
drawings and models that were unveiled
at a formal banquet at
the St. Francis Hotel.
Now, of course, designs
are created quickly
and distributed even more quickly.
Everyone sees images of
new buildings instantly
on Instagram and Twitter
and everywhere else.
You hardly have to wait months or years
to learn what is getting built.
This means that if you were
a real estate developer
who wants to make a mark,
you want the latest thing instantly.
Architecture has never
been immune from fashion,
but it seems more tightly
bound to trend today
than ever before.
I think it's important to say again,
that it's not just because
of famous architects
that too many buildings in too many cities
look the same.
The vast forces of globalization
push relentlessly toward homogenization,
and most cities are
powerless to push back.
On the rare occasions when
they do push back successfully,
it's often the celebrated architects
who provide the best alternative
to standard-issue commercial banality,
who do the pushing back, so to speak.
And if that comes in the form
of somewhat similar
buildings from city to city,
we need to remember that
this is not a new phenomenon.
So am I saying, therefore,
that generic is okay?
That it is just something
we learn to live with?
No, despite the fact that generic
was not invented in our time,
that doesn't make it desirable.
I don't think that
acknowledging the enormity
of the forces of globalization
and recognizing that they are too large
for any city fully to resist,
therefore means that we have to lie down
and play dead before them.
We want places to feel distinctive.
Believing that you are in a place
that is not entirely like other places
is important not only
for the places themselves
but for us.
We receive a critical part of our identity
from where we are, most
importantly from where we live,
but also from where we are
even for brief periods.
If every place looks and feels the same
then we are to a degree,
perhaps more than we wish,
also the same.
Cities need to play to their strengths
if they are to retain a sense of identity,
which is to say that
they need to recognize
what it is that they have
that makes them distinctive
even if all are not in a position
to become quite as
distinctive as San Francisco.
Knowing what to do of
course is another matter.
As Daniel Burnham's
miscalculation 110 years ago
reminds us, it is possible to understand
and respect the essence of a place
and still come up with
the wrong response to it.
A more contemporary example
might be up the coast
in Vancouver, which as you surely know,
is an exceptionally pleasant City.
It has a beautiful waterfront,
expansive parks, appealing
downtown neighborhoods
and jaw-dropping scenery.
The breathtaking mountains
are, by and large,
protected from overdevelopment.
The only thing the place
lacks is architecture
that you can remember for
more than five minutes.
The city's skyline filled with
gleaming new office towers
and high-rise condominiums is deadly dull.
Vancouver does all the right things.
It's planners really do
understand urban design
and they know how to make
streets in public places.
They believe in density,
and they believe in walkability,
two critical elements for a city,
and it's a joy to walk
around Downtown Vancouver
which is more than you
can say for many cities.
But why is it not an equal joy
to look at the skyline?
Why in this place that
is itself so distinctive
is the skyline so generic?
if the lesson the San Francisco
Street Grid teaches us
is that it is sometimes
necessary to be counterintuitive
and to juxtapose the plainest
and most conventional thing
with an unconventional context.
I think the lesson Vancouver
offers is different.
It is that you need architecture
at least some of the time.
If streets are more
important than buildings
to making a city work,
and I absolutely believe
that they are, architecture still matters,
and something somewhere
has to be memorable.
Now Vancouver has no risk
of becoming truly generic.
Its scenery, not to
mention its benign climate,
ever-present waterfront and wonderful food
will always save it from
falling into the chasm
of the ordinary.
But most of the architecture of that city
puts the majesty of the
scenery to the test.
When you have your back to
the water and the mountains
you are no longer in a distinctive place.
Creatively responding
to what is distinctive
about the culture or the
physical setting of a city
is the first way that a
city can resist the push
toward the generic.
But as we've seen in both
San Francisco and Vancouver,
it is not always eager to figure out
what that response should be.
What goes hand-in-hand with
these things is preservation,
holding on to what you have,
knowing it will become
all the more precious
as time goes on because
it cannot be recreated.
Historic preservation
increasingly means neighborhoods
not single buildings,
which often looks forlorn
not to say ridiculous when they are adrift
in a city of utterly different things.
We could spend an entire afternoon
talking only about issues
of historic preservation,
so let me say here only that since we know
it is becoming harder and
harder to create places
that are distinctive and that
the natural order of things
does not bring us to them.
We have all the more
obligation to protect those
that have been handed down to us,
to learn from them yes,
but less to preserve them
like precious hothouse orchids
and more to integrate them
into modern life.
And then of course a
city needs to be willing
to trust in architecture to help.
It cannot save the day, but it can
make an extraordinary difference.
I am saying this not to give a free pass
to famous architects, but to acknowledge
that while making a coherent whole
and making civilized
decent background buildings
is the greatest mission of urban design,
even the best urban fabric is not enough.
We also need exciting special buildings
that excite the emotions.
Those buildings that, as the critic
and historian Lewis Mumford wrote,
caused people to hold their breath
for a stabbing moment or that restore them
to equilibrium by offering them
a prospect of space and
form joyfully mastered.
Yes, if you try to make an
entire city of such buildings
the result is chaos, but that hardly means
that we don't need some of them.
One of the silliest
aspects of the backlash
against star architects is
its implicit presumption
that if you think that
special one-of-a-kind
distinctive buildings are good,
then you must think that every building
ought to be like that.
And since every building
should not be like that
then the logic goes, no
building should be like that,
no building should be exceptional.
Nothing could be more ridiculous.
Of course, Frank Gehry is
not a model for anything
except Frank Gehry and
his buildings work best
when they have the chance to play off
against the everyday buildings
that make up the urban fabric.
But we are in danger these days
of losing our belief in special buildings.
Largely, I think, because we
have asked too much of them.
We've asked them to
shoulder the entire burden
of making cities, and they
cannot and should not do that.
When did believing in the urban fabric
and believing in the
ability of architecture
to bring us special
exhilarating intense moments
become incompatible with each other.
We have got to begin to believe
in both of these things again.
Every city needs to be a place
in which the basic idea of urban fabric
of streets and public places
and decent but not
spectacular architecture
forms the foundation.
But if that is all we have,
and if we lose our desire
for great and special buildings
that break out of all of this
then we have failed our
cities just as much.
The generic city is not only the place
with identical glass towers
and freeways and malls.
It is also the place that stops caring
about things that are different
and no longer builds
buildings that break the rules
and make you feel that you are in a place
that is like no place else.
And that, the feeling of
being in a special place,
is one of the greatest gifts
that any city can give us.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Mary] Thank you very
much, thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- [Mary] Thank you Paul,
that was a wonderful lecture
and we will have some
time for a few questions.
We would ask people to keep
their questions relatively brief
so that everybody can have a chance.
And I will just put the microphone here
and please ask your questions at the mic.
- Hope we didn't answer every
possible question in this.
- [Woman] I'll take a quick stab.
- Sure.
- [Woman] You're talking about,
you mentioned mediocre architecture
and not that you need to go on,
I think we know what you're talking about.
But what about the term
vernacular architecture.
Could you talk about that a little bit.
- Sure, it's a good,
that's actually a word
that I could have been should have
probably woven into this somewhere.
The term vernacular
architecture, which is,
this sort of meaning the
common everyday language.
What I was saying, even though I wasn't
clever enough to put it
in exactly these words,
was that in fact we lack
a good vernacular today
and other periods had it.
I mean the great failure
of modern architecture
is not an inability to
make great buildings
it makes plenty of them,
it has never made a successful vernacular.
If you look at the Victorian architecture
of San Francisco, the
brownstones of New York,
the Georgian architecture of London,
even the most ordinary buildings
in that vernacular were wonderful
and they made a civilized
and beautiful city together.
We have not been able to create
a modern equivalent of that.
So I think that, in many
ways, is our greatest problem
and I think it is also one of the reasons
that the preservation movement
grew as large and as
important a factor as it is
in the sort of culture
of building let's say.
I mean the deep dark secret
is how much preservation
is motivated not by love
of what is being saved
but by fear of what might
replace it, in fact.
(audience laughs)
That's, so anyway, yes sir.
- [Man] You talked about
buildings they are too big,
could you expand on that concept?
- About buildings that are too big.
I did talk about buildings
that are too big.
I did not mean by that to suggest
that there is not a place for
very, very large buildings.
But only that the average new building
that so much that is being
built today is so big
that we have we have seen a
significant change in scale
in our cities, and that
is an enormous challenge.
I actually love skyscrapers.
I wrote a book about them.
I love tall buildings.
Some of my very favorite
things in the world
are very, very tall, very,
very large buildings.
I am not, that was not a cover
for everything should be six stories high.
I was not saying that at all.
But there is a a sense of balance
in a city and we have lost that
in so many of our downtowns now.
That's all I meant to say by that point.
- [Man] So actually I
question along a similar line
which is you were
mentioning that there were,
and there certainly are,
cities full of buildings
that you felt are too big and too many
and often too much the same.
But what I was wondering is
what the alternative was,
so I presume the alternative
is having an enormous number
of smaller buildings.
And I wonder whether it could be hard
to have much distinctiveness
if you had that many smaller buildings
or whether when you have the investment
in a big building you
can get the starchitect
to build something distinctive.
- You know, San Francisco,
I don't mean to sort of
make this all that local a talk
and yet on the other hand
I do have to go back to think about
how reasonably successful
San Francisco has been
in creating a sort of urban vernacular
of small to medium size
urban buildings in downtown,
many of which are really extremely decent,
some of which are more than that
and in which modern architecture
does begin to have a certain degree
of life and vibrancy to it,
and yet still be quite urbane.
In general, I think you do,
though, make a better city
with more dense lower buildings.
I mean look at Paris for example,
not that we're going to ever
remake our cities that way.
But it's awfully nice when it happens.
But of course that alone
is not enough either
because if you look at
much of Washington D.C.,
it is also eight story buildings
built out to the street
and it's pretty dreary, most of it.
And so, I mean, who would rather walk,
who wouldn't rather walk in Paris
than Washington D.C.
So there are many, many other factors
that come into play here.
I'm gonna talk actually about Paris
and San Francisco some
more tomorrow as well.
Yeah, Dick.
- [Dick] So when I was
young in San Francisco
we've referred to our two iconic banks
as one was the Bank of Italy.
- Right.
- [Dick] And the other of
course was Wells Fargo.
So a couple weeks ago I was
in Charlotte, North Carolina,
and someone proudly pointed out
that the hometown banks were Wells Fargo
and Bank of America that now dominates.
And it got me thinking
about, wherever I go
I have this, we all have this presence
of enormous wealth
that's being moved around
and it's one more way that the,
because wealth dictates
a lot of the buildings
that go in, and how this is shaping
this homogenization of
everything around us.
So I just wanna maybe
reflect on what you just said
and think about it a
little more if you would.
- Sure, actually tomorrow I'm gonna talk
a certain amount about
the sort of massive
movement of global capital
creating these sort of huge things
that seem to really be
commodity investments
more than buildings
often, and what it means.
The fact that the Bank of America
which was once the Bank
of Italy in San Francisco
and is now the Bank of
America in Charlotte,
and Wells Fargo, is in
fact as good a reminder
as you can about the the
fact that all of this
is about the movement of global capital
and the cities are just the byproduct
and sometimes the waste product (laughs)
of that whole process.
Although, you know of course it has things
that make life easier for us
as well as things that make us hard.
I mean I Bank at Chase in New York
and when I landed at the airport
there was the Chase machine
just like the one in New York
and how did we ever live
without these things.
So that it, there are so many ways
in which this technology
and culture benefits us
as well as challenges us.
But, you know, it is so often
the same people
building the same things
with the same money
and the same architects
for the same tenants
in different places.
That in some ways I wonder
why are we surprised that things
are coming out the same.
But all of that said,
I think it's important
to reflect on the point that I made
about 19th and early
20th century buildings
which was that we were building
a lot of similar things
all over the place then too,
and we were not so unhappy about it.
So the notion that architecture,
that architects and
builders do similar things
at similar times in different places
is not new to our time.
But what is new to our time, I think,
is a weakening of a local culture
brought about in part
by the homogenization
of global culture and technology
that makes the places themselves less able
to assert an identity, less
able to create an identity
in the first place, than they were.
And we will see how all this plays out
but I'm not encouraged about that.
I'm encouraged about a lot of individual
works of architecture and not encouraged
about our ability to make
places remain distinctive.
So, anyway.
Yes sir.
- [Man] Hi, thank you.
You framed your praise for localism
with praise for walkability.
- Right.
- [Man] And this little city
has a history of innovation
both culturally and architecturally
to the point where Berkeley
is kind of a shorthand for things
and you were kind enough to
mention Maybeck's legacy.
I would predict that if you
come back here in 10 years
this city will be
unrecognizably homogenized
by a lot of major development
that's being greenwashed
with appeals to things like
walkability and livability.
And it all seems to be
inspired by somewhere else
by places like one word stereotypes
like Portlandia or Park Slope
and none of it's really rooted here.
And I get around by bicycle,
I'm wearing bicycle
clips just to frame this,
but does does every place
have to be walkable?
Does every place, is there a dark side
to a good movement.
- Now there's a great,
wonderfully perverse question.
Does every place have to be walkable.
I think that's a very
fair question to raise.
First I would say we are
in very little danger
of every place being walkable. (laughs)
We should only be lucky enough
for that to be the real
issue and the real problem.
Every place is simply
never going to be walkable.
But what I do see happening,
and I think this is to the good,
is a greater respect for the values
that are inherent in
that word walkability,
and to see it existing
in sort of nodal ways
in lots of places that
are in a larger sense,
in a macro sense, not walkable.
Los Angeles is probably
the best example of that.
I mean there are more neighborhoods today
in Los Angeles that have a street life
and are walkable than there used to be,
in part, and here's the law
of unintended consequences,
in part because traffic on the freeways
has gotten so utterly unbearable
that it was too much trouble to go across.
I remember when I first
went to Los Angeles
many, many years ago,
you would think nothing
of zipping from Malibu to downtown
and then back to Santa
Monica and then to Hollywood
and so forth all within a day.
Well it would take you
a week to do that now.
So in fact, the unexpected
consequence of that
is that more neighborhoods
now have good restaurants,
good shopping, attractive streets,
cultural facilities and so forth
and the city is actually a set of nodes,
many of which on a small scale
for certain every day functions,
function walkably but
then there's the overlay
of the macrocity that people deal with
in a different way.
That's not a terrible
adaptation of a model.
I mean it's a model we would not
wanna create that way from scratch now
but it's evolved in an interesting way.
Does every place have
to look like Portland?
I hope not.
I think Portland is a lovely place
but it would be a shame if everything
sort of really did become like that.
And you know Park Slope too.
But I think, what you
make fun of in Park Slope
is kind of the culture of it
more than the physical fact of the place
which is, and here's a good,
another interesting thing
about a lot of traditional cities.
Park Slope has a physical
fabric of brownstones,
a park, a few special buildings
but a larger fabric dominating everything
and then a couple of
nice commercial streets,
is a model for almost any kind of life
and it works really well.
It doesn't require the silliness
of the Park Slope food cooperative
or whatever all that stuff is
that people make fun of there to exist.
A different kind of life could also exist
very fruitfully there.
So I think it's also important not to,
while we must never fail
to give proper credence
to physical form and its
impact on life and culture,
I think it's also a mistake to believe
that it determines all.
'Cause sometimes they just coexist
without having quite as
much of a cause-and-effect
relationship on each other.
That's what I think.
Yes sir.
- [Man] So one of the great
and probably justified criticisms
of the starchitects of the last generation
was their complete, the
way in which they ignored
the street context and people,
the big empty plaza and all that.
Do you think the new generation
of architects that you talked about,
the star architects who
are going around the world
are they still creating sculptures in situ
or are they focusing more
on the life around them?
- Well I don't think
that a sort of building
that's a significant and
assertive piece of sculpture
necessarily is anti-urban
and avoids the street.
Some do, some don't.
I've seen plenty that are
in fact quite sophisticated
and subtle from an urbanistic standpoint.
It all depends on the circumstances
and who's doing it and
a million other things.
But yes I see much more
consciousness of that today
and much less comfort
with either breaking away from the street
or if you are making a public space,
with making it cold and
unsociable let's say
for want of a better term.
I think the work of William H. Whyte,
who I actually referred
to early in the talk
was critical and I think
that has sort of been
pretty much absorbed into the culture.
I was going through the New Whitney Museum
in New York the other day
and talking to the director
and he was talking to me about this little
sort of mini Piazza that
is at the front of it,
between where you get
off the High Line Park
and go into the museum, and he was saying,
oh you know we're, he said,
I'm sorry you're seeing it today
'cause the chairs haven't arrived.
We've ordered all these
chairs like they have
in the Tourville in Paris,
these little light chairs
that people can move
around any way they want.
And he didn't even say, oh, you know,
we've done this radical thing.
He just sort of mentioned that
as if that's what people do now.
So I think that that
we have learned a lot.
It doesn't mean we do everything right.
But we, I think, have learned
more about public space
than we had before.
And architects, when they
are doing large-scale
major projects, I think don't
try to convince the world
that an acre of Travertine is
in everybody's best interest.
Yes sir.
- [Man] Inasmuch as you are speaking
of the effect of good architecture
and creating a sense of
uniqueness of a city,
I'm surprised you haven't
mentioned Gaudi and Barcelona.
Nothing could be more a perfect example.
Gaudi, and I'm an architect,
and we toured that,
spent days looking at Gaudi's stuff.
Pure genius.
I thought Frank Lloyd Wright was the tops
but Gaudi is my man now.
(audience laughs)
And the other person is Calatrava.
- [Woman] Oh yeah.
- [Man] Very imaginative.
And unlike Frank Gehry, who I
don't have much respect for,
we did Bilbao, very, very good.
Everything else seems hit and run
where he does his shtick and
just sticks his wild stuff on.
But the planning of the building itself
is not good.
- Well, I would agree with
you completely about Gaudi
and yes I could certainly
have mentioned him.
I didn't think so, but
I didn't think to do so,
but, and the talk was
a little long as it was
but you're absolutely right.
It is completely
consistent with the points
I was trying to make.
There are actually many reasons
why Barcelona is an extraordinary
and distinctive city.
Gaudi is the most
important but also the plan
with those chamfered corners
of that whole section
there are many things
about it that are amazing
of which Gaudi, as I
said, is the most eminent.
I don't agree with you about Frank Gehry
but that's a longer story
for another time. (laughs)
And I think Walt Disney
Concert Hall in Los Angeles
in particular is an extraordinary
and beautifully planned
and eminently successful public building,
particularly on the inside.
But that will be another
another conversation
for another time anyway.
Yes sir.
- [Man] Thank you very much,
and I really enjoyed your talk.
- Thank you.
- [Man] I was fulfilled
and had no questions.
And then your soliloquy here
in the question and answer period
discussing the flow of, massive
flows of capital, basically.
Christopher Leinberger's arguments
17 standard product types,
because that's what's
financeable every day.
In some ways anticipating your talk today,
The Generic City, I thought
that was gonna be the punch line.
Can you tell me why
you didn't mention that
in today's talk?
- Why I didn't.
- Why you didn't.
- Mention what's financeable?
- [Man] Well yeah, the fact that
what's what's financing the generic city
is a sort of development mechanism
which is standard across
the US and now globally.
- I sort of took that almost
as implicit, that's why.
I mean I don't disagree with you.
- [Man] Yeah were very explicit afterwards
and I agree with you, which is probably.
- I mean I now, I hope I get a chance
to do some version of
this talk somewhere else
because all of you are very good editors
and you're actually, you've
given me several points
to sort of add in and in
fact, that's, you're right
I think I probably should not have
made that implicit, I should
have made it explicit,
because it is absolutely right that
the forces of finance
play a far greater role
in shaping cities than architects do.
However, that said, the
nature of what is financeable
has evolved and changed.
And there was a time not all that long ago
when a strange building by Zaha Hadid,
Norman Foster, Jean
Nouvel, Frank Gehry even,
was utterly unfinanceable.
Frank Gehry is now doing condo towers
for the Related Group,
the New York developer
and has done other things.
So that you, we have also watched
some evolution in that world.
It lags, obviously,
architectural creativity
by quite a bit, but it has,
it has been affected by architecture
as much as it has affected architecture
in the last few years.
And I think that in itself
is a fascinating phenomenon
which could be a talk in
itself as well, in fact.
I'm gonna talk, as I said,
I said a little bit more
about all this tomorrow
in another context.
Thank you all very much again.
(audience applauds)
- [Mary] Yes, please join me
in thanking Paul Goldberger.
(light upbeat music)